[Music]
beat Sabre should be your go-to workout
for cardio because since we're already
addicted to it we may as well embrace
the benefits the oculus quest is
seriously the best system to use for the
beat Sabre workout because you can go
anywhere to do it there are no wires to
trip over while you're dodging walls and
the headset is really light so you don't
get that hurt EVR neck thing it's like
it was made for it or something
according to the VR Health Institute yep
that's a real thing beat saber burns six
to eight calories per minute which is
the same as tennis or jogging 5 miles
per hour
neither of which I would ever do beat
saber tricks you into working out
initially so you don't even know you're
exercising but once you come to terms
with it you'll start looking for ways to
make your beat saber workout even better
the oculus quest is step one of that
here are some other tips adjust your
grip the oculus touch controllers are
made to fit comfortably in anyone's
hands while allowing access to all the
buttons you may wish to adjust your grip
when using beat Sabre as a workout
though so when you swing you can easily
hold onto the controller and ensure the
grip is maintained through the entire
workout especially if you're sweaty turn
on the no fail option since the time
that you spend not sabering to the beat
during your workout drops your heart
rate and lessens the quality of the
workout it's better that you don't fail
out of the songs the no fail option
keeps you swinging even if you're
missing the beat you'll either get
better as time goes on or you just have
no rhythm either way you'll get a good
workout
fully swing you're probably already
doing this since you get more points for
swings that start at a 90 degree angle
and extend a full 60 degrees but that
helps you get more of an extension and
burn from each movement also it feels
really good to get max points from a
level and this is the only way to do it
overreact to obstacles add full side
steps and squats to avoid walls like
your Indiana Jones you might look a
little silly but that's no reason to
forget leg day speed up the song if you
get to a place that you want to increase
the cardiovascular effects of your beat
sabering train creasing the speed
slightly it'll make it harder to do
everything but you're moving faster and
burning more calories paired with the no
fail option you can just fail your way
to a great workout now let's get to our
favorite workout songs from the official
beat Sabre song list tell it's over is a
great song to start your workout it is
three minutes and 43 seconds which is a
bit longer than most of the official
songs but has a relatively low beat per
minute so you can start slower
now killing yourself this song has great
use of obstacles to get your blood
flowing in quite a bit of what I like to
call double swing blocks which are great
for core work next upcountry rounds this
song has one of the highest beats per
minute in the game so it's really gonna
get you pumped but it has a moderate
level of notes per second which are
notes actually flying at you each second
high energy with a slightly easier skill
level is great for your warmup
commercial pumping has the highest notes
per second on this list it's only a 1
minute 20 second song but the amount of
slices required starts burning
especially if you're already a few
minutes into your workout it has great
arm crossing sections moments that
require sidestepping
and those double swing blocks I
mentioned before next up is a hundred
dollar bill the obstacles will keep you
moving but the real reason I love this
song is the way the blocks make you do
circular motions to complete the map it
feels great if you run through it a
couple of times the song is really fast
and really fun and has accessible notes
per second so you can clear the level
relatively easily and still get a great
burn our favorite song to work out - his
angel voices which is the longest song
in all of the free DLC coming in at just
over 6 minutes the burn is so strong
with this one when played at expert +
difficulty it has fast sections with
brief moments of calm so you can
contemplate how much more of the song is
coming down the pipe at you it's great
no matter what level of beat saber you
are you can just adjust your beat saber
to fit your needs and still get a great
workout
[Music]